I'm wanjang and a question for the boys
hello
um if you're hello
um when you're looking for someone and
you're looking for someone to love and
to settle down with
what are you looking for like beyond
having a baby like personality what are
you looking for in a personality
virgin 18 not annoying Cooks I said
personality not traits these are wrong
that's not a personality being a virgin
isn't a personality you'd be surprised
I think you need to go online shopping
for that one because he's just right
here
well the kind of it's a personality
because it's based upon choices like do
you know what I mean by like personality
so when I'm looking for someone right I
want somebody that's going to be funny I
want somebody that's going to be
adventurous I want somebody that's going
to go around the world with me and have
a lot of fun and be like a best friend
right I'm gonna have that like goofy
girl that I can roll around with and
stuff and have fun with every Tinder
profile yeah in reality
does this seem real to you I thought I
had it I did I thought that I did have
it I did it I just think I think
sometimes like you know Society tells
women we can just have everything in a
guy we don't have to be we want him to
be stable but we also want him to travel
the world with us yeah but we did do
that five or five years I don't know
what you're what your personal stuff is
but you're not with him now so it didn't
seem to work out I know
it was pretty amazing about that like
I'm someone that like
I I sometimes think oh do I have to
and I hate the word settle for less
because I I feel like oh my God I'm
taking on this you know but there is
parts of me that I'm like okay well I
want a man to do this I kind of want him
to because I I have a very flexible life
with my my job
um I've always worked for myself like
but I'm free because you know work
happens when it happens and that's good
for me so I'm like okay Thursday night
or Thursday daytime who wants to go on a
date and that's not possible for a man
that's working hard or doing the things
that I also want so from if I'm like oh
I just want to go to Paris for the
weekend he might not be able to do that
and I have to I'm really trying to start
thinking like okay well this if I'm
having to think of a man that I want for
the rest of my life like where or what
am I gonna have to start compromising
because it's not that I I don't think I
can have it all but I don't think all is
like um sorry my love what she said um
at the same time well and I think I
think we never really acknowledge that
men compromise on us constantly I think
most men would prefer most men would
prefer virgins I think most men would
prefer women that have cookbooks I think
most men would prefer women that could
stay home and homeschool the kids but
what percent of modern women can do that
I don't think it's most men
trust me it's most important but you're
in an echo chamber I think if you put if
you in front of any dude and you gave
him what they'll just described yeah and
then you give him what he actually has
again that's the type of guy no I think
but if most guys don't have options
that's the thing you don't understand
that most guys literally have zero
options so they get they just take
whatever they can get most guys are
literally just grabbing for scraps
seriously they don't get the woman they
want they get the woman they can get
talk to any man honestly
one out of three men are either virgins
or one out of three men are either
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year under 30 one out of three yeah do
you think one out of three women are
sexless no definitely you know the guys
that pray we need to wait we need to
wake up I feel like
it might not sound the way we want to
hear it sometimes it's actually reality
hear it sometimes if you go back to
Stats or you know and I I do and I I
think with us women sometimes we we
pursue what we want and we forget times
out of ten we're gonna get what we want
because yeah it's us but with a man
unless you do and I'm just speaking
generally unless you do have a nice job
and you're attractive to whatever degree
society says is attractive and you have
this they're they're not
even something as silly as this I always
think about this if like a female wanted
to go out tonight and find someone to
sleep with
it's a it's guaranteed I I don't want to
say I but if I wanted to walk out to die
some other woman
but what is a man I'm thinking about it
the
we are as women we're very entitled
um
you need to no no I'm just thinking of
generally I'm just thinking you need to
take a female out on a first of all
approach her nicely
look good look look the part take her
out on a date have someone to take her
because obviously you can't take her to
um her house because that's very bummy
you need to have your own place you've
got to take me to your mom's house it
takes a lot before he gets his sweat but
we're gonna get that wet I mean we could
we could even we could set up an account
yeah with the girls on the show
we can set one up for the girls and one
for the guys
it's just reality when you take time to
think about things that are outside like
yeah that things are not affecting you
you start to think past what's actually
it's true you're not but you've got to
remember you're you're looking at
pockets of types of people in a
demographic so I always like to say the
types of people that go to Oceana
the types of people that go together in
general when we're having General
conversations we can't talk about
everything yeah everywhere so yeah yeah
okay there are certain pockets and I was
on no jumper I don't know if you guys
know about the jumper that was a wild
pocket of people what's that house it's
it's um it's run by a corn star like two
Corns do they have 80 like yeah
yeah yeah I mean they're just wild and
on that and you know maybe the guy's
there because
certainly not you but but some corn
Stars seem to be more forgiving guys
with because they date each other do you
know what this is the podcast I listened
to you on and I thought what a beautiful
sort of like moment where you got to
talk to him because he was giving like
all he talks like all of my friends he's
like he doesn't care he's just like I'm
not jealous I love the fact that my
woman is able to be free with her body
and I was listening to him say these
things and it was like
he sounds brainwashed honestly like I
really like him but I'm just like that
doesn't seem it is not I know but it's
different opinions it is not no it's not
no his opinion is based upon everything
that is pushed by mainstream Hollywood
mainstream media mainstream like TV
mainstream music his opinion is from
what I'm understanding about the guy but
that kind of acceptance is purely based
around everything that the mainstream
media is driving into men's brain into
childhood when in history have men Ever
Wanted promiscuous woman when has the
average information times
where they used to have a huge cheese
anyone from the township actually
and those women were revered those women
were revered goddesses they were not so
stop I will not stop it
did I tell you I was Greek yes
but honestly that was the whole thing
that you know goddesses were a really
big part of that culture before we had
Christianity and Catholicism sort of
like brought into commonplace there was
quite a lot more goddesses within
religion and it was beautiful you know
there's um there's still only about
eight or nine matriarchs left in
societies today up to four million
because they don't work